go I just wanted quickly your thoughts
yay or nay on cotour should Xbox save it
100% that is theirs it should have never
gone anywhere else facts bring it
inhouse figure out who's going to make
this game now figure out what you want
the game to be because my thinking is I
mean obviously we
Sean yeah give it to obsidian absolutely
they made two right now decide what you
want it to be do you want it to be a
remake in the vein of like a ff7 and
turn the turn base into
hybrid action term based or make it
fullterm based but it has to be
beautiful it has to be cinematic it has
to really be a remake that stands toe
to- toe I think with an ff7 remake or
things of that nature has to dark s
let's
go do s got to do emperor Emperor things
executive 66 they call you do s right
there and then cuz I know you need um
also finish your thought and then I had
to get I want to just I mean for me yes
save it that is yours that is associated
with you it should have never gone any
place else it is time to bring that back
but you got to do it right and you
decide whether if it's turnbas or hybrid
but I think either way it has to be a
beautiful game it has to be cinematic it
really has to bring that game back uh as
a pure triaa knock your socks off game
got you final question um this is your
topic so I want to let you get your ball
um what would where were you going with
the Embrace of layoffs cuz I'm just
going to let you get your balls off and
we probably skip that time um yeah go go
go right ahead um you have to Microsoft
yes ink is dry oh ink is dry they they
held the bag like King said they it held
the line okay time to pounce there are
some IP there this is personally for me
y need y'all need to sa which one uh you
need to go grab up that Legacy of Kane F
Vic this actually you know what's funny
there is so many they own that they they
it could be a flash sell man they really
and even if they don't make the games
they can always license them out for
movies and TV shows cuz that's been the
new big thing okay but I mean pick and
choose to what that you know what IPS
you want from there see if the teams
that are actually working on them have
the expertise to bring out you know
whatever type of game that is I
understand you still need the middle
ground game you still need the doublea
game loving going on on this screen I'm
sorry I thought it was Valentine's Day
in the realm for someone but we go oh d
this is x-rated ad it I just joking it's
getting hot over there continue sorry
but yeah that's my thought sad obviously
they they they they really overstepped
they really really Lin stepped with this
and they they took on all these IP they
took on all of these Dev Studios and did
didn't think about you know what it
would take to bring these things to
Market as viable products that people
want to buy um we saw it with Gollum
we've seen they were other they had them
stimulus checks yeah the stimulus they
were rocking they were they were living
above their me you know how when you
when you live beyond your means got you
got them stemies boy you was out here
you thought you was Bim boy oh I mean we
saw it they shut down volition and I'm
going be honest like I I did not like
that Saints Ro reboot but
volition give volition the chance to go
back don't make them scared of their old
games and try to make another game in
that vein it's been long enough that I
think people will accept it but now
that's dead right rels to the win so um
yeah man grab up whatever IP you think
can be relevant moving forward I can see
if k please um and and and let's see
what's there but obviously though I want
these IP to come back in a real
way some of these really do deserve to
be fullon AAA game so I mean if smaller
Dev Studios make their way to some of
these IP cool but I really do some of
think some of this stuff can be
reimagined into big budget sort of brand
new things we'll see no doubt all right
brother enjoy your it's going to be a
crazy couple of weeks I love yall I
hopefully make it next week and the week
after no promises but I love you love
love you too brother love you I will C I
will certainly come on to gloat if I win
you don't need to show up for the crown
your lord results I promise I promise
that all you will be doing is showing up
and passing me your
crowns all right brother enjoy peace
we're going to go back to the first uh
topic for us which was the um actually
yes this next year I want I want a crown
uh a crown your lord trophy made yeah we
got to do something for him win again oh
and when you if you win the next year
the person that has it has to it to yeah
we got to take it from like how weed
should do with I'm put it right here
yeah yeah you can remind people who the
chat is all right cotour Captain sa game
Xbox come on that's what we doing kour
make
doing should they come in there save
okay so this is where I have a bit of
conundrum done with this game right all
right they go in there they save the
game the game doesn't come out to Snuff
oh see see that's what Sony uh dropped
ity Sony knew that it was good and they
walked away from it the IP was poisoned
because it was Microsoft dead
fruit um and then XBox guys some some
dudes that never even played the damn G
um oh they need to go get it they need
to they you can't have another scale
bound can't have another scale bound
this ain't scale bound boy like I don't
know um if it's not going to be done in
the way of Final Fantasy remake like
it's okay Resident Evil uh 2
remake that stuff I want stuff like that
okay if you're going to remake something
I want you to go down to the to to the
ground I want want you to go into a
great Direction I want you to see what
the original plan was did they live up
to the original plan if they didn't live
up to the original plan how can you get
to the original plan um can you do it
episodically can you do certain things
because if you going to be in Game Pass
if you're going to purchase it you can
have one of you can have cotour as an
episodic game that's inside uh Game Pass
well the same way that they doing Final
Fantasy they breaking that joint up oh
you talking about a full remake stat
okay my bad my full REM that's taken um
you know give you real chunks of the
first game to get to the hole um because
that's episodic technically you know you
got to wait for part two you know um
Final Fantasy but
um I I'm just like you're damned if you
do you're damned if you
don't but me personally as a person that
play CTO and like the game and you know
I'm a fan of dark
rev yeah um you know Malik and everybody
I'm I'm going to tell you Microsoft if
you're going to do it don't don't half
ass it yeah don't do that because you
would do more harm than good in doing
that if you're going to do it give it a
full budget have a a studio uh mapped
out and bring the best technology going
forward to it because if you mess that
up you're
mud yeah I feel that adct Xbox Captain
Save A game can they do it should they
jump in I don't I would like here's the
thing MD's pissed he said XBox if it's
legal for them to do it because I don't
know if I would assume that
PlayStation's dropped all support for
this game at this point you know they
they privated the videos like it does
seem like they were trying to like sever
the relationship they had with the
company and the game so if that has
happened and Microsoft is able to jump
in here and save this game I would
particularly only want it to happen if
they actually fund it and find a good
Studio I don't I want them to do it in
house right or a studio that we know
would do justice like Lor Studios
obsidian yeah if they're going to
Outsource this yeah let them buy lauan
Studios you're right I don't want them
to I don't want them to to just throw
this to anyone if you're not going to
give it like King said the Resident Evil
4 Final Fantasy 7 uh remake treatment
just let it go don't don't don't don't
go any further want to give you all an
update from Jason Shri cuz remember the
talk initially in the beginning of the
week where MADD he's he's going storm
he's going to storm the capital when he
heard was going to be cancel he's uh was
um that now Jason Shri says can't say
whether the CTO remake will actually
come out but yes two people from saber
interactive tell me they're still on it
despite recent rumors that nobody's
working on the game saber took the
project from Aspire last year as
Bloomberg reported and then Jason says
the demo wasn't egregiously bad or
anything like that the bigger issue was
misalignment between all the parties
about scope and how much progress they
can make within a given timeline so he's
saying it's still on don't know if it's
going to come out and he's trying to say
that the devil wasn't bad but I guess
the scope was either too big and they
know how long it's going to take for him
to make it so now uh saber has it
instead of aspire to to to me I don't
really like all that means is someone's
working I'm sure there's people working
on factions right now probably not
many probably the only people working on
both of these games is the people that's
deciding if it gets canceled or not so
it's just like I need to like see actual
progression like people what scale like
I CU there could be so many scopes of
scale that these companies could be
working on is there literally just to
like it's just to me if Jon shrier is
unsure if the game's going to be
finished or not the people that told him
they're working on it they're really
like they're not even sure because to me
if the people work on it's like no
everything's good we we settled stuff
we're good but they didn't say that to
Jason sh because he even said he's
unsure so to me at this point the only
people that know whether or not this
game's coming out Is Us in the the
future because even the people working
on it don't know yeah they don't know if
it's actually going to come out yeah
they said it but they're working on it
now jump in um look I'm with the overall
po point with uh Maddie and S that I do
feel it should have never gotten here
because bro that joint Maddie reminded
me he has the OG Xbox only on Xbox it
said only on X this joint was also part
of the Xbox OG box art as a game you
could get with the system so I don't
know why what that yeah to me this is
like Mass Effect one energy where you
had something and you you know what I
mean like you let this kind of slip
through so you should have been first
I'm kind of mad that PlayStation was
able to jump through salute to
PlayStation like see the foresight but I
will
say what the hell did Inspire show Sony
that made them go oh no we are walking
away from this
completely go ahead K what what you what
you think
they gave him the the the
bill they said they said they they gave
him the white board and they said okay
so what we have over here this is all
the stuff that we're working on and this
is all the stuff that we plan to achieve
and um right now financially what y'all
have uh this the bub we looking for is
is this right here but what we need to
get to here is this right here and they
slid the note on the table and Jim slid
it back and said now for that price now
not with that engine we won't be going
forward with this
relation bro for Sony to snatch an
exclusive and that is this should be a
slam I let you know how broke they are
like y'all going to stop playing around
why can't be that Aspire joint was not h
no I it was it was hot I know it was hot
like yo I you know what everybody Sizzle
real lit everybody Sizzle real lit until
you get the actual game we saw red real
and we was like yo that's hot that's hot
son like yo we saw for spoking she was
jumping around that's hot son what if
they came in in spit super ugly n n they
didn't they didn't I know they came in
there they spent super pricey and these
dudes was like you know how you go to
take a girl out you're G to go eat and
she start talking about going to roof
Chris and she you like she to yeah yeah
I could come pick you up she's like nah
I meet you at the restaurant just send
the Uber for to get me to go to hell no
like where you at with this you bugged
out so like Factory and that's what's
happening that's exactly we going to CH
y like I want to go with Mr CH
Sal was like
no okay so the scope the budget that's
where you were it was the budget I know
these dudes man I know how broke they
are I know when they start sliding
checks across the table you know how
when they send right here pay this bill
they push it right back listen this
should have been a slam duck it's Star
Wars and it's existing IP it's a beloved
this is like a easy you already got the
foundation on the Remake right d like I
I'm shocked that this didn't go down so
that is interesting now saber is on it
my only issue what's up go ahead I'm
imagine imagine announcing you dating my
ex that it come out you couldn't afford
man don't do him like that don't do like
that y could go through with anything I
got your girl like yo I got your boo
everybody man oh man they work with
together now then you come to find out
now he couldn't even they a't even
together he can't afford to dat to keep
up with the payments oh man not like
this said I want my hair and nails done
Sony not like this K not like this you
are messy your financi yous tell me the
truth so this would have went down if
they could have afforded it that's the
only reason why it couldn't because the
game itself was not quality they can't
afford it if Microsoft would have
announced it we know it was coming
out these dudes talk about they got
stuff coming out we don't know what's
up you're ridiculous y'all couldn't
afford
cot you are ridiculous
anyway oh look all I was going to say is
now obviously saber interactive has it
is a new new person that that's going to
be taken over a new new chick according
to King that has it and um the only
thing I know is like like for Xbox is
can they realistically do anything was
there anything contractually in place
that say yo remember when they sned up
snagged the exclusivity Sony did does
that end with a Spire now that saber has
it could somebody jump in could could
Xbox do the Double Dutch jump you know
jump in type jint we're going to see um
I will say I agree completely with adct
though if Xbox is able to get
involved to me there is only one logical
choice there's only one choice who
should grab this and no disrespect say
interactive I know you guys forgot the
gentleman's name I interviewed him he's
awesome Matthew har they made them um
NBA playground games that I did like but
anyway um back on track the only one who
should be doing is if XBox has control
is the Black Rock obsidian come to the
front of the table you did cotor too and
obsidian been known and be like yo is a
project available we love to work with
whoever whatever get him a license IP
Star Wars I would love that to happen if
it's contractually able if obsidian is
free schedule wise they got a team they
want to do it joshu hey what's up man
joshu what's up that's me that's me but
I think it's it's a slam D if again Xbox
is able to and again no disrespect you
saber but you you can't play with this
we it has to be quality you can't be
messing up C I'm not